thank you all this is one of the last
photographs I have of my grandfather
I've taken it on his 87th birthday about
seven months before he passed away he
had Alzheimer's and in this photograph
he was five and a half years into his
battle with the disease
this photo reminds me of everything he
was an optimist a fighter to the very
end but this photo also reminds me of my
family's journey the many bad days in
the occasional good day when it started
with misplaced keys and frantic phone
calls eventually gave way to personality
changes aggression depression and
eventually loss of all function my dad
and his brother looked after Baba
my grandfather through all of his
illness but eventually it became so
overwhelming for them that we needed a
full-time caregiver nothing had prepared
them for the physical and emotional
demands of caregiving even though I work
in the healthcare industry I doubt I
would have been any more ready in their
situation you see as my grandfather was
going through his illness I look for
solutions that could ease the caregiving
burden on my dad and my uncle and I
could improve the quality of my
grandfather's life has Alzheimer's
ravaged his brain but I found very
little mostly informational websites a
few support groups and some products
that don't really work do you worry
about caring for an aging parent or
grandparent I do too and working in the
health care industry
I worry a little bit more because I know
that we face a much greater challenge
than our parents did and I also know
that the current health care system
unless changed will fall short of what
we need you and I are going to be the
caregiver generation and we will need
better solutions so today I want to
explore what we hear in the GSB
community future investors entrepreneurs
executives can do to make a difference
to this issue that matters to all of us
let me start with a few numbers we have
40 million people over the age of 65 in
the u.s. today they form 13% of our
population or 1 in 8 by 2050 they will
form 20% of our population or one in
five today we have five taxpayers to pay
for the care of every senior in the
country by 2050 we will have only three
2050 is not that far it's only 35 years
away and we will experience the impact
of these numbers in our lifetimes not
only will be face a greater share of the
cost of care we will also face a greater
burden and here's why people are living
longer the average life expectancy is 78
years today and is inching up into the
right into the 80s the fastest-growing
segment of our population today is
people over the age of 85 fewer people
today die from heart disease and stroke
but the prevalence of chronic conditions
such as cancers and diabetes remains
high and dementia
which is linked to age is expected to
become an epidemic and in fact it's set
to become the sixth leading cause of
death among seniors surpassing diabetes
the health care system was designed for
acute care and procedures not to take
care of people with chronic conditions
over a long period of time and in fact
about 40 million seniors only 2 million
live in assisted care facilities and
skilled nursing homes 38 million live in
the community in their homes and that's
where we will need to care for them as
you all know Medicare reimbursements
have been declining but what you
probably didn't know is that the cost of
uncompensated care or the care provided
by families you and I accounts for four
hundred and fifty billion dollars on an
annual basis and lasts on average eight
years we should expect those numbers to
increase and this is not just a US only
issue countries like China Japan and
even India that people consider to be a
young country also faceless challenge
for instance today in India those over
the age of sixty two five
the elderly account for 8% of the
population by 2050 that will be 20% or
323 million people more than the current
population of the US this is a real
problem and it's a big one and a global
one some of this will require national
policy changes and it will require
medical advances but I see a real
opportunity for all of us here at the
GSB and today I want to talk about two
opportunities in particular product
innovation and reimagining extreme users
let's start with product innovation and
no I'm not talking about incontinence
products and walkers what I am talking
about is smart solutions that help
seniors live healthier more independent
lives for longer connected to the people
that they love in their homes technology
things that we do so well here in the
valley
sensors wearables mobile touchscreen
have such a tremendous potential to
create better tools for seniors and
their caregivers and let me show you a
few examples of what I'm talking about
lift labs us-rok Health startup created
lifts where a spoon for people with
Parkinson's disease it works just like
your iPhone camera it detects shake and
cancel said and allows people with
Parkinson's to feed themselves here's
another example the beef shoe I don't
know how many of you knew Falls
yes Falls are a 30 billion dollar
problem in the u.s. Falls happen when
our footprint moves out of our center of
gravity while you and I can self-correct
Berkeley seniors can't and so they fall
and they fall more often but when they
do fall the consequences are often
catastrophic between 15 and 20% of the
Falls lead to a pape a hip fracture and
50% of the people who suffer fit
fractures
died within a year it's staggering many
solutions have been tried to this
problem with little success the B shoe
is taking a novel approach with
accelerometers what they do is detective
fall that's about to take place and
force a senior to take a step backwards
helping them regain their balance before
they fall
and here's another example lift here on
a Stanford startup out of stamp out of
Steve blanks lean launchpad class they
created uber for seniors to help to help
seniors get to doctor's appointments the
grocery store and do other things that
make up their daily lives when they can
no longer drive so my point is you don't
have to be a health care expert a
medical doctor to be an entrepreneur in
this space and quite honestly there's
actually never been a better time to be
an entrepreneur in this space reducing
the cost of senior care which forms a
vast majority of the healthcare costs in
the u.s. is a national priority and the
key players the government the AARP
health insurers and health systems are
getting behind it I I don't know if you
all knew but this is leading to the
creation of an emerging and thriving
ecosystem of startups that are starting
to come into this space startup health
data shows that the number of startups
in the space increased 33 percent
between 2012 and 2013 and funding
increased sixty percent over the same
period the AARP estimates a twenty
billion dollar opportunity and that is
just in the next five years and only in
the US even if you choose not to be an
entrepreneur in this space I'd urge you
to still look at opportunities in this
segment which is an increasingly
important part of the consumer market
and this brings me to the second
opportunity I want to talk about
reimagining the extreme user Katie FICO
was speaking at Stanford not too long
ago is the co-founder of aging 2.0 a
network for entrepreneurs and investors
in the space and Katie said something
which was quite interesting she said if
you designed for seniors chances are
that your products will find a bigger
market if it's intuitive to them it will
be intuitive to many not too long before
my grandfather passed away I was
visiting him I was sitting by his
bedside looking at old photographs of us
scrolling through my iPad he was
watching me and at one moment he reached
over and took the iPad from my
and without my prompting him his finger
slid across the screen and for a moment
I saw his eyes light up as the memories
came back I saw a smile wash across his
face it was a magical moment I was so
shocked I couldn't imagine that in his
condition when he didn't know the day of
the week it was he could operate an iPad
with no instruction and that it made him
happy
Katy's words were true we are going to
be the caregiver generation and we will
need better solutions so this is what I
ask if you are a GSB student looking for
a startup idea I hope you will consider
opportunities in this space if you are
at a start-up or at a company I hope you
will look at the segment with a renewed
lens and if you're an investor I hope
you will fund ideas that can make a
difference to all of us but here is one
thing we can all do today call your
parents and your grandparents and tell
them that you care they will appreciate
that call let's go change lives the
lives of the people we love thank you